i've invested over the years since 2009
to that
we're talking about millions of dollars
into growing a business i mean
if you build a uh if you build a
building you know for whatever is a
coffee shop a pizza parlor
and then someone comes in and says by
the way we're taking back the foundation
no i paid for that
and we agreed to that and if you change
the rules well first off there's some
legality there and then
tell me what the new rules are do i need
to pay for updates to the foundation
what do you have to corner the building
um they haven't given us any answers so
this is the only option available
to me not the first
i think something too is you know bill's
always known that i've approached us as
a business owner
you know this when people see me
complain about something publicly you
know we do a d platform this campaign or
something like that's because the fight
has come to my doorstep
i want to be able to run my program and
run my business
and we even said look look if you have
different rules from what we've been
told
tell us what they are now that's one
thing that happened at least at that
time of the vox adpocalypse where they
said okay
these videos need to be removed you need
to change your shirt and your merch
store which
was different they added guidelines
again sorry
because i hadn't violated any but then i
said okay your sandbox your rules
understood with facebook they still
haven't given it there's
no answer no reply no reason for
removing
the biggest election stream that's ever
taken place in an online platform by the
way more people were watching and i
don't say this to to brag i mean you
know we've talked about this for a long
time a lot of people go out there and
try and tout their numbers i want the
content to speak for itself
more people were watching us than brian
williams and cnn combined and facebook
gave
no reason to this day zero justification
for it
at a certain point you have to know what
the rules are didn't we
didn't they just so was it friday they
just yeah now they just totally
demonetize the page
which is fine what was the reason listed
none none whatsoever i've invested over
the years since
2009 to that we're talking about
millions of dollars into
growing a business i mean if you build a
uh if you build a building you know for
whatever is a coffee shop a pizza parlor
and then someone comes in and says by
the way we're taking back the foundation
no i paid for that
and we agreed to that and if you change
the rules well first off there's some
legality there and then
tell me what the new rules are do i need
to pay for updates to the foundation
what do you have to corner the building
um they haven't given us any answers so
this is the only option available to me
not the first what would you guys say
to all of the media matters people and
the vox people
and the daily beast people who no doubt
will be watching this and they will say
but wait a minute
crowder and your half asian lawyer uh
when we look at the top ten you know
drivers of traffic
to facebook pages you know usually four
out of ten have something to do with ben
shapiro
three of them are the blaze and you know
then there's one lefty thing how could
that
how could that then be uh the censorship
of conservative voices
that's actually that's in spite of
facebook's policy
now we don't know because we don't have
access to the information algorithms
which are kept more secret than the coke
formula or
was it the 52 herbs and spices to the
colonel's chicken
but i will say this you know people used
to use this argument a lot about about
michael phelps
they would say well he eats uh three big
macs every day and he used to eat a
bunch of mcdonald's and this kind of
stuff and people say so that
therefore that must be the diet of
champions no he has the wingspan of an
albatross and a size 19 triple wide shoe
and so he can get away with eating
mcdonald's and still
being the best swimmer in the world
because of god-given
athletic capabilities i would say as it
relates to conservative content
listen the left has had all of maine abc
nbc cbs cnn msnbc
fox news really up until recently being
the only one
new york times washington po everything
right com places you just mentioned
daily beast vox right and these places
are all owned by multinational
uh uh media conglomerates like we've
been in tussles with
uh disney nbc is it then or is it disney
abc
nbc universal target.com viacom all of
them
never lost any of them um and so i think
that a lot of people go online for the
same reason this show has been as
successful as it is
for something that is an alternative
point of view alternative to what
everything else and so the fact that
people are
craving truth and information that they
cannot find
anywhere on their television dial um
that
conservative shouldn't be faulted for
that it's just that the left listen they
have had every other platform
and they're not nearly as competitive uh
here on facebook right now so just
just because they're more successful
doesn't mean that that's because
facebook's favoring them and there's
so to jump off of that dave real quick
is is really what it comes down to
is that the in spite of argument is very
true it's not about
how much is actually being shown it's
how much would have otherwise been shown
if you had enforced your
policies correctly and if at the end
facebook's one of their arguments one of
their defenses might be
our platform sucks people don't like it
that's why we're not getting that much
views that's why the streams aren't
doing as well uh you know our stuff just
broke down
we have no reason like it's just we're
actually really bad at what we do
that might be one of their defenses so
but ultimately it's about what should
have been
not about what they're actually
providing despite the fact that there
are numerous
um conservative platforms and voices
that aren't getting good traction to
spike the policies
it's nonetheless doesn't speak to the
second point which is the individual
question about certain voices
there are certain voices that have
gotten more attention in a bad way
from the powers that be whether it's
youtube twitter or facebook and stephen
is one of those when you look back at
the 2016 gizmodo article
that example there was based on only
having four names of all the
conservative voices out there at the
time
you had rush you had daily wire you had
shapiro you had all these other names
that were out there you were out there
one of the names that was out there
maybe not
fully in the conservative sphere at that
point but when you have all those names
that only a few were targeted you have
to
ask the question of why and so our
lawsuit is not about
saying that there's this widespread top
to bottom
every single person is there saying they
hate conservatives what it's about is
saying
if you can bend the rules without giving
full business disclosure if you can
commit
fraud that is anti-competitive one media
company
complaining to another media company to
shut down a third media company
if all of that is legal then you don't
have laws anymore
you don't have an equal playing field
that the law guarantees
we're not saying that we want to change
the rules we're saying enforce the rules
as you have stated them
and if not be honest about what the real
rules are tell us what you're doing
tell us how you're enforcing it don't
wait until it's a senate inquiry or a
facebook whistleblower though i will
tell you people are coming out of the
woodwork to talk about what's going on
and it's only getting worse yeah crowder
as a guy that's been doing this forever
don't you kind of
admire the elegance of their evil in a
certain way like oh yeah
i have i have no doubt that you see the
same things that i see like there are
certain weeks
when they let my videos be seen like
you're out there we're getting the
normal numbers
or twitter you know suddenly i can get
thousands of retweets on
everything and then there's suddenly a
week where i'm purging followers and
i get five retweets on something like
that that
sort of elegance by design of just
keeping us all on our toes constantly
so that we can't be like oh there's the
smoking gun because every freaking week
something else happens yeah uh no game
has to respect game
when you look at me like okay kind of
like right now with the merrick garland
like remember me i'm like
ah that's one for you okay all right
fair play uh no you're absolutely right
i mean listen the reason that we haven't
been hurt
uh on youtube for example with traffic
so uh
this is separate from facebook is
because we know that you can be beholden
to algorithms to search to browse to
suggest it and so we plug every time we
do a show look just tune in monday
through thursday
10 a.m eastern we've set a schedule
that's not something that's really
typical of online content doing it live
at a set time a good portion of our
traffic comes from people
just bookmarking the page so that we
aren't in matt drudge before he went you
know
who met judges today uh he said don't be
beholden to these social media ghettos
now
that doesn't mean that everybody else
has had to come up with contingency plan
over contingency plan for their business
model
but we have we've always had to try and
look around those corners so
the fact that we have for example the
fact that we have uh
you know millions of people tuning into
these shows on on on youtube
um doesn't that's not necessarily
because we're showing up in browser
suggested all the time it's because
we have planned for this this this
scenario
where we are never suggested and so
we've had to act accordingly
and uh listen that makes us more
competitive and i think that
conservatives in general are pretty
pretty industrious i don't know about
the top ten uh but i can tell you what
traffic we were getting at facebook once
upon a time
versus now um i can tell you how often
we were trending versus now i can only
tell you about my experience
and then i'd like to compare notes with
facebook but uh they don't answer
at all ever period yeah it's like
well google i mean if you were to forget
us right like forget us the guys that do
this for a living but if the average
person had a problem with their gmail
account
who are you gonna call right like
there's no there's no phone number
yeah i'm sure nobody could co would
yitzke will get right on that
yeah yeah yeah they'll she'll be all
over it
um does any of this just seem like
the obvious end game of where
all of the kind of social justice lunacy
that you and i have been screaming about
for years
was gonna go in other words that these
companies have
chosen the social justice ideology
they've chosen the equity ideology
they've chosen to have you know their
board have a certain amount of trans
people and gay people
and guys like you and i we rail against
this stuff so it's like
this shouldn't surprise us right that
they would try to go after someone like
you
um no it doesn't surprise me i've always
sort of had a target on my back that
doesn't surprise me
what does surprise me is the flagrant
disregard for
like bill was laying out just basic
honest business practices you know i
mean if you change the rules let us know
i don't think we violated any rules with
the election stream if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about
comedy instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else check out our
comedy playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell